sharon osbourne also from great britain
wrote this tribute to the queen today
quote rest in peace queen elizabeth ii
the embodiment of strength dignity an
unwavering commitment to her vow
may you be at peace beside his royal
highness the prince philip duke of
edinburgh long live the king
sharon osborne is joining fox soon by
the way as a host at fox nation and we
are happy to have her tonight sharon
thanks so much for coming on what a
sweet and heartfelt
lines series of lines that was
that reflects how you feel obviously
absolutely it does i mean i had the
honor to meet the queen many times
she
i mean look at the woman has gone
through in her life she swore her oath
to her country she has never put a foot
wrong she
has put up with so much and
you know there's there is nothing bad
anyone could ever say about the woman
it would be impossible she has served
her country
i i don't think there's any disputing
that is
what you just said is that a common view
do you think in the uk tonight
absolutely i mean talking to all my
friends my family
everyone everyone is in mourning
for her majesty everyone
i i hate even to ask this but what
happens next with king charles
i'm
i adore him i i think he is going to
make a great king
and
you know i he's been waiting a long time
he's you know he's been
he knows what he has to do how many
years has he been watching his mother
and learning from his mother and his
father
and i think he is going to stand in as
king and i think that he will be a great
king
so you you think the monarchy will
continue
i hope so i'm a royalist and i i really
really hope so
amazing i had i i had no idea you're a
realist and and of course i have to i
have to ask you because i can't control
myself
meghan markle
where does she fit in to all of this
to the royal family
well right
so there were reports that she was not
participating in the morning is that
true
i don't know i honestly don't know but
um as far as the royal family are
concerned harry and megan step back
so
as far as the future of the royal family
i don't think that
they will be of service to their country
or the commonwealth because they chose
to step back and you know they do their
own thing and that's it
yeah they certainly they certainly do
they do their own thing and that's
nicely put sharon osborne thank you so
much for joining us
thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight